hi marvel fans i am here with victoria
alonso executive producer how are you
doing great i'm excited now zendaya is
coming so that's the party right there
we got a party going on here too we we
had a yes today is a good day today is a
good day we get to celebrate spider-man
one of my favorite characters not not
their favorite but one of my
one of my nice save
and they're all my favorites tonight is
a big night this is the biggest
spider-man film
that we've seen today and the effects
and are on a whole nother level can you
talk about that just a little bit just
there's just so much that went into this
you know the thing about working on
these things it just feels during the
pandemic this took
far more effort because we were not
together
and i think that what i longed for is to
be together again
but we got it done thanks to the six
thousand plus people across the world so
i thank every single vendor facility
human artist and family member that put
up with us working from home and
hopefully you can all go see it and
keep the secrets
i thought you were going to tell us a
secret
i'll say no are you kidding me
i don't know i'm not saying anything
okay all right all right what are you
most excited about with this film
tonight i'm excited to see how people
react to something that we've been it's
been with us for so long
so i'm just ready
ready for all of you to know what i know
okay well i'm ready for that too
um
how did you and your team pull this off
um
well you know every movie takes a lot of
effort so it just it was uh effort
effort effort and we have the best team
you know amy kevin we have john watts
who's fantastic and we have a beautiful
trio and zendaya and tom and jake and uh
the friends are back they're back in
town so they get to tell another story
that's beautiful
what does this night mean to you
i hope i hope that this gift of uh
filmmaking that we put out there to the
world is received with as much love as
we made it
oh
that made my heart feel like mushy i
love that well i don't want to keep you
enjoy the rest of your red carpet i look
forward to seeing the film thank you
thank you for your support and if i
don't uh see any more i think that's it
for this year we have nine projects that
came this year happy holidays we
represented with all of our hearts so
we'll see you after this we'll see you
next year all right see ya thank you
[Music]